when we're looking at polar coordinates
one of the important issues is to
understand the unit vectors let's
describe our coordinate system again we
have a point where there is an object
and at this point we have a pair of unit
vectors R hat and theta now those unit
vectors will change depending where you
are in space we now want to address the
question how do I compare polar
coordinates and Cartesian coordinates in
Cartesian coordinates at this point here
we would have let's say we choose a
Cartesian plus X and plus y then we
would have a unit vector I hat and J hat
and how are these vectors related
remember our angle theta so we have the
angle theta here and the angle theta
there and now I would like to apply
simple vector decomposition to our hat
and theta hat and express each of these
unit vectors in terms of the unit
vectors I had and J hat let's begin with
our hat as you can see in the diagram
our hat has a horizontal component and a
vertical component so what we have is
our hat it's a unit vector so it's
length is 1 its horizontal component is
adjacent to the angle so that's cosine
of theta I hat plus sine of theta J hat
the vertical component is opposite the
angle in a similar fashion theta hat
well theta hat has a component in the
negative I hat direction which is
opposite the angle and it has a
component in the positive J hat
direction which is adjacent to the angle
so we have minus sine theta J I hat plus
cosine theta J hat and that's how we can
decompose our unit vectors R hat and
theta hat in terms of Cartesian
coordinates now why is this significant
because if we're describing the motion
of an object for instance an object
that's going around a circle then our
polar coordinate theta
is a function of time and so these unit
vectors are actually changing in
direction we saw that before over here
our hat and theta hat point in different
directions so what we actually have as
functions of time is our head of t
equals cosine theta of t I hat now the
unit vectors don't change in Cartesian
coordinates at every single point you
have the same Cartesian unit vectors and
so these vectors this vector is time
dependent now the significance of that
is our first important vector in
kinematics is the position vector the
position vector is a vector that goes
from the origin to where the object is
we'll call that R of T so this position
vector R of T can be expressed as a
length R and its direction is in the R
hat direction which is a function of
time so we have R cosine theta of T I
hat plus R sine theta of T J hat now we
can now define the velocity of this
object where the velocity is the
derivative of the position vector when
you differentiate remember R is a
constant so we get R now what is the
derivative with respect to time of
cosine theta T because the argument of
theta is a function of T we need to use
a chain rule so the derivative is minus
sine theta of T D theta DT I had and the
derivative of the sine is cosine theta
of T D theta DT
jae-ha now notice that I can pull out
the common term D theta DT so I have R D
theta DT and I have minus sine
fate of T I have plus cosine theta of T
J hat and if you'll notice this is
exactly the unit vector theta hat so we
can write our velocity vector for this
object it's moving in a circle as R d
theta DT theta hat when we write a
vector like this it's pointing
tangentially the theta hat direction and
this part is the component so often we
can use a notation V theta theta hat
where V theta is the component Rd theta
DT now this component can be positive or
negative or zero for example if D theta
DT is positive what does that mean that
means that our angle theta is increasing
so the object is moving the way I
indicate with my finger if d theta DT is
zero then the angle is not changing so
the object is at rest and finally if D
theta DT is negative and the angle theta
is decreasing and so the object is
moving in this direction so this is our
velocity for a circular motion in
expressed in polar coordinates